bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches
l'émission qui ne se cache pas derrière
un masque
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler de la dette
peut-on l'annuler bonjour restait
bonjour olivier bonjour à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouvel épisode de ses caches en
épisode consacré cette semaine vous
l'avez dit olivier à la dette si la
crise a lié aux copies de 19 est avant
tout et sanitaires les répercussions sur
l'économie sont nombreuses à commencer
par la dette pour financer leurs
différents plans dette les ita les états
n'hésitent pas à emprunter massivement
en creusant bien évidemment les déficits
en france par exemple ministre de
l'action et des comptes publics gérald
darmanin a fait une première estimation
à la mi-avril du déficit public et de la
dette pour l'année 2020
au programme une contraction du pib de
8% cette année un déficit d'environ 9%
et une dette publique 215% contre 81,18
initialement prévu autre exemple en
italie où la dette qui était déjà la
deuxième plus élevé de la zone euro
après celle de la grèce en 2010 934
dégueu 8% du pib devrait a continué à se
creuser pour atteindre 158 9 % en 2020
olivier est ce qu'il faut s'inquiéter de
ses dettes qui ne cesse de gonfler
évidemment qu'il faut s'inquiéter
puisque une dette c2c de l'impôt futur
donc ça veut dire que ils vont monter
les impôts alors même si darmana
évidemment nous jure ses grands dieux
que ils ne monteront pas les impôts ils
vont les monter d'ici la fin de l'année
est une évidence ils vont créer d'autres
aussi vous aurez un impôt de solidarité
pour le colis là
qui touchera à peu près tout le monde et
tout ça pour régler les dettes qu'ils
vont mettre en place
pourquoi tout simplement parce que c'est
pas assez pas dû aux colis d'un c'est
comme ça qu'on fonctionne depuis déjà
plusieurs années est en tout cas depuis
2008 on a fait de la dette parce que on
sait pas faire autre chose et que ces
gens là n'ont absolument aucune
imagination donc qu'il est beaucoup plus
facile de faire de la dette le qui sera
réglée par nous plus tard par nos
enfants plus tard et donc c'est la
méthode la plus facile il espère en
rajoutant de la dette à des gens qui
sont qui seront déjà surendettés que ça
va relancer les choses ça ne relancera
pas grand chose à mon avis et est donc
ça mais en aucun cas la solution mais
c'est la solution qu'on avait déjà
adopté en 2008 2009 et qu'on reprend
maintenant parce que parce que je vous
dis ils ont appris ça dans leur petit
bouquin à l'ena et qui sont pas beaucoup
d'imagination donc qui continue à faire
ce que ils savent faire le mieux c'est à
dire dépenser notre argent est ce qui
est arrivé est ce qu'il ya d'autres
moyens que la dette pour financer toutes
ses dépenses mais déjà il faudrait pas
les faire ces dépenses c'est à dire que
depuis le départ
toute cette opération est gérée en dépit
du bon sens je voulais dit plusieurs
fois acheté des masques et acheter des
tests ça coûte beaucoup moins cher que
de bloquer complètement une économie et
donc de se retrouver obligés de 2to
garantir et croyez moi c'est pas fini là
on en est qu'au début
aujourd'hui dans l'économie réelle on a
que le début des choses c'est après que
ça va se passer c'est quand on va mais
confiné qu'on va s'apercevoir que vous
avez plein de gens qui aujourd'hui ont
arrêté leur
activités qui vont pas pouvoir leur
prendre parce qu'ils ont fait faillite
entre temps et c'est là qu'on va
commencer à voir les trous se former
dans les banques dans les assurances et
et c'est là qu'on va malheureusement
être obligé de les combler et qu'est-ce
que qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire
ils vont encore une fois maîtres de la
dette par tous sachez quand même que
quand vous surendettés comme ça en fait
vous appartenez à celui qui vous prêtent
de l'argent alors c'est soit l'état soit
une banque mais vous lui appartenait
totalement donc il faut bien y réfléchir
avant d'accepter les aides de l'état qui
sont notre argent je vous rappelle
l'état c'est pas un c'est pas un
ectoplasme avec un gros chéquier 1 c
c'est nous merci à beaucoup olivier on
passa tout de suite à la deuxième partie
de cette émission
et cette semaine nous sommes en liaison
avec hubert de vauplane avocat ancien
banquier bonjour monsieur ne veut pas de
vauplane bonsoir merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté de participer à cette émission
alors on l'a dit en première partie à
une dette de 115% du pib en france est
annoncée pour 2020 158,9 % en italie
concrètement qui détient ses dettes pour
la dette française sait c'est peu madame
michu
c'est pour beaucoup d investisseurs
qu'on appelle institutionnels donc
banques assurances françaises bien sûr
pour une partie une autre partie les
mêmes et en europe
et puis une très grosse partie qui est
grosso modo entre le quart et le tiers
et base c'est la bce avait la banque de
france c'est à dire qu'une partie de la
dette publique française elle est
détenue finalement par la banque
centrale européenne via la banque de
france d'où les idées de certains dont
on va parler tout à l'heure de dire bah
c'est très simple et calmer cette partie
de la dette mais cette dette elle et
contrairement la dette italienne
traditionnel dette japonaise qui sont
plutôt des tenues par les les résidents
italiens ou japonais pour une bonne
partie note elle est peu détenue par des
institutionnels par des personnes
françaises si je puis dire
donc on n'a pas la maîtrise de notre
dette n'ayant pas la mettrie de 90 de
nos dettes on est effectivement à la
main de nos créanciers olivier monsieur
de vauplane je voudrais enfin réagir à
ces propos de christopher dembik
responsable de la recherche
macroéconomique du groupe saxo bank
cela n'a aucune pertinence de regarder
le pourcentage de la dette en pib ce
qu'il faut regarder c'est la charge de
la dette qu'il est sur la dette et qui
rachète la dette est ce que vous êtes
aussi de cet avis monsieur de vaud plein
en fait c'est un débat assez classique
dans le monde économique et dans le
monde de la politique monétaire et de
dire peu importe le niveau d'endettement
peu importe le notionnel le capital de
la ds qui est important c'est le service
de la dette
tant que je suis capable de payer mes
intérêts aux créanciers de la dette
le niveau d'endettement de la dette
importe c'est quelque chose qu'on attend
beaucoup en ce moment et qui est de dire
mais c'est sur la confiance que les
investisseurs ont sur le service de la
dette que finalement une économie un
état peut continuer de s'endetter au
delà des seuils qu'on nous a présenté
pendant très longtemps comme des seuils
infranchissable que ce soit au dessus ou
en dessous de 6% du pib avec les notions
de dette soutenable et c'est donc ici là
le service de la dette c'est finalement
peu importe le capital qui ne sera de
fait pas remboursé puisque j'emprunterai
de nouveau pour rembourser et donc ce
qui est important c'est de pouvoir payer
les intérêts c'est ça c'est qu'on entend
de plus en plus olivier une réaction à
ce que j'en avais fait de plusieurs
réactions d'abord la première quand vous
disiez que la dette en france n'était
pas détenu par madame michu mais par les
institutionnels
oui sauf que les institutionnels travail
pour madame michu c'est à dire
l'assurance vie
c'est de la dette les produits bancaires
c'est de la dette
le livret a c'est aussi en grande partie
de la dette et donc vous êtes de toute
façon dès que vous avez de l'assurance
vie ou un de ses produits
vous avez de la dette des états donc
dire que madame michu oui madame michu
ne l'a pas directement mais elle l'a
tout de même au japon en revanche là
aussi vous nous dites que ce sont les
japonais qui détiennent la dette
japonaise
c'était vrai il ya quelques années c'est
archi faux maintenant c'est la belgique
qui détient la bête japonaise et non pas
les japonais est entièrement la dette
japonaise là pour le coup puisque elle
achète 70 % de tout ce qui se présente
sur le marché donc sur la réflexion
monsieur d'un big c c'est habituel
c'est-à-dire en fait quand on arrive sur
des niveaux qui sont très excessifs on
cherche à changer le thermomètre
c'est quand même beaucoup plus facile
que d'essayer de comprendre pourquoi ça
se passe alors évidemment en termes
absolus savoir si ça fait 80 % ou 90% ou
100% du pib ou maintenant en tout cas
dans tous les pays occidentaux la dette
et a beaucoup plus que 100% du pib donc
maintenant on a on a cassé ses soldats
et depuis un moment déjà
sachez que la dette en fait si vous la
calculer correctement
elle est beaucoup plus élevé en france
que les 115 % qu'on nous annonce mais
peu importe ces grecs c'est le service
de la dette qui compte pourquoi parce
que quand vous avez 100% du pib et que
vous prenez un pour cent de taux et bien
si vous faites un pour cent de
croissance
votre croissance en fait nuls elle est
annulée par le service de la dette donc
le problème c'est pas tellement
d'ailleurs le pourcentage par rapport au
pib
c'est qu'on a plus de croissance quand
vous avez d une croissance de 5 % de
votre pib que vous avez une dette qui
représente 50% votre pib et que vous
avez des taux à 3 % mais ça ne pose
aucun problème
d'accord parce que vous avez de la
croissance qui est largement suffisante
pour payer vos intérêts là aujourd'hui
le problème c'est qu'on n'a pas de
croissance
on a pas de croissance et on a une dette
qui enfle
tous les ans et c'est ce qui va se
passer d'ailleurs puisqu'on se japonaise
tous en ce moment c'est ce qui va se
passer c'est à dire que on est on sera
peut-être si on prend les chiffres de
monsieur darmanin à 115 à la fin de
l'année et puis on sera à 125 l'année
suivante et on sera à 130 et ça n'en
finit plus et on se retrouve très
exactement comme les japonais avec 250 %
des essais de vos peines et avant de
passer à l'assiette une réaction à ce
que vous venez à ce que les environs
l'évier c'est un débat très économistes
sur lequel moi je suis frappé de voir en
tant que banquier enfin anciens
banquiers avocats que là-dessus la
science économique de tout le monde le
sait n'est pas une science exacte et que
donc on a des avis très partagés
on a souvent entendu qu'ils avaient des
seuils de soutenabilité de la dette
au-delà de laquelle c'était la
catastrophe
là dessus effectivement je rejoins ce
qui a été dit puisque lors de la crise
grecque on nous a dit oulala 127 points
5 du pib au delà c'est à dire 128 c'est
plus possible pour tous ces chiffres-là
explose aujourd'hui est finalement
s'aperçoit que les tabous d'hier on en
reviendra pour l'annulation mais les
tabous d'hier sont sur la table
aujourd'hui et les tabous du pib
n'empêche pas de se dire bon c'est quand
même une question à un moment où il faut
qu'on réfléchisse une dette
c'est un peu bête mais c'est quand même
ce qu'a rappelé le gouverneur de la
banque de france une dette ça doit être
remboursé une dette
sinon se révèle pas une dette cédant
s'appelle une rente
on en reparlera aussi mais dead c'est un
contrat dans lequel il ya prêteurs un
emprunteur donc une dette n'est pas
remboursé ça marche pas on remarque une
courte pause et on se retrouve dans un
instant bienvenue dans ces caches si
vous nous rejoignez on parle de la dette
alors justement monsieur de vos peines
vous parlez d'alu nation la question de
l'annulation de la dette a été mise sur
la table
elle ces dernières semaines pour
christine lagarde la patronne de la bce
l'annulation de la dette ne serait que
ne serait-ce que partiel est totalement
impensable
est-ce possible monsieur de vauplane
d'annuler la dette
est ce une bonne idée déjà le nom
annulation faut voir ce qu'ils
recouvrent parce que là aussi je suis
frappé de voir qu'on emploie des mots
qui ont des connaissances
quand des sens juridique qui sont pas
exactement les mêmes on peut faire comme
thomas sankara qui est dans sa président
du burkina faso qui en 1987 deux mois
avant d'être assassiné avait fait un
discours indices abeba disant je paierai
pu mais créanciers parce que c'est le
sang du peuple ça c'est pas une
annulation qui s'appelle une réputation
de dette
on peut aussi faire un abandon de
créance
ici ce sont les créanciers qui décide
qui décide d'abandonner une partie de
leurs créances annuler la dette c'est
quoi c'est l'acte unilatéral ça la
décision unilatérale de thomas sankara
mais qui dit je paye plus et un seul
pays qui l'a fait c'est encore
moyennement se dire c'est l'équateur
bon après encore monter au mexique en
1883 ont pu remonter plus loin aussi
mais dans un temps récent l'annuler
sauver dette c'est-à-dire un état qui
dit je rembourse plus ça c'est pas vu ça
c'est pas une annulation
c'est une restructuration c'est un
accord avec les créanciers mais c'est
pas une annulation
là ce dont on parle en termes c'est le
point sur lequel christine lagarde s'est
avancé c'était la question deux pour le
coût de l'annulation de la dette détenue
par la banque centrale européenne
une vraie annulation ce qu'a dit
mélenchon d'ailleurs dans un c
qu' il ya quinze jours en disant mais on
peut tout à fait annuler cette dette
puisque c'est quasiment un jeu à somme
nulle
ce sera une bonne idée alors là aussi il
ya tout un débat qui dira où là on peut
pas annuler la dette de la banque
centrale qui ne tue pas la banque
centrale européenne ou la banque de
france en l'occurrence puisque ça ferait
passer la banque centrale européenne à
des fonds propres négatifs donc prendre
un exemple fait pas un exemple
d'ailleurs le montant des fonds propres
de le bce je crois c'est celle de mme
hill 5 milliards d'euros fin 2010 9
et puis elle a en face de celle de ses
7,5 milliards d'euros
l'acca 1500 milliards de dette donc vous
faites le rapport pour une entreprise
commerciale et serait en faillite depuis
longtemps avec le juge car immédiatement
prononcé une liquidation judiciaire
mais justement la bce n'est pas une
entreprise commerciale ordinaire puisque
lé peut faire la planche à billets
autant qu'elle le veut tout ça pour dire
quand même que annulé de la dette qui
est détenu par la bce ferait que ces 7,5
milliards d'euros se trouverait de
manière négative et so what et alors et
alors que certains aient alors disent
certains la première question c'est là
que je prends ma casquette d'avocat
c'est que c'est pas si facile d'annuler
la dette mélenchon il nous dit c'est pas
compliqué vous réunissez tout ce beau
monde auprès d'eux des gouverneurs dans
la salle de réunion de la bce il décide
d'annuler la dette
ben non il ya des traités européens
c'est pas si facile que ça alors en aval
et on va voir les modalités du peuple un
olivier est ce que ce serait une bonne
idée selon vous d'annuler cette dette
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ce que
les idées économiques de monsieur
mélenchon je me méfie un peu
parce que entre monsieur mélenchon et
madame lagarde
on a quand même le niveau zéro de
l'économie donc non évidemment non parce
que d'abord comme le dit notre invité il
y aquelques propres outils problème
juridique qui ceux qui se posent et puis
on va rentrer là dedans on annule la
dette alors je suppose que ce qui veut
dire c'est qu'on annule la dette qui est
uniquement détenus par la banque
centrale puisque celle qui est détenu
par les français ou par les
institutionnels mais par les français
par le truchement des institutionnels
et bien si vous l'annulez je conseil à
monsieur macron après de ne plus sortir
de l'elysée parce que il va en fâcher
quand même beaucoup
donc si on annule uniquement la dette
qui est détenu par là par la bce
je dirais c1 c'est un système un peu un
peu facile où on crée de la dette sur
commande les politiques vont se
précipiter dans le dans le dans ce
jeu-là en demandant la banque centrale
finalement deux d'annuler toutes les
bêtes qui sont en train de créer et donc
vous n'avez plus de limites mais la
limite c'est quoi c'est la planche à
billets qui aura en contrepartie c'est à
dire que à force de créer deux des
billets pour racheter cette cette dette
est ensuite de l'annuler et bien
vous risquez fortement une perte de
confiance totale de d autres pays et de
la population en verve envers sa monnaie
et sa monnaie kiss cool c'est tout c'est
parce que si c'est si facile à ce moment
là moi ce que je propose c'est que on a
eu tous imprimés n'oubliez et puis qu'on
a ce qu'on aille tous surtout demandé
aux banquiers d'annuler nos têtes mais
c'est de voeckler pardon monsieur de
vauplane si on décide d'annuler la dette
détenue par la bce comment ça se passe
comment on fait concrètement
ben ça s'appellerait ici il ya deux
modalités
il ya la modalité la plus la plus
drastique qui est un abandon de créance
dont une annulation en abordant créances
bien le créancier la banque centrale
décide d'abord donné la créance
juridiquement on comptablement on sait
faire c'est un jeu d'écritures
comptables dans lequel d'un vous
supprimez la créance qui est inscrite
dans votre bilan
et puis en face c'est pas parce que vous
supprimez la créance vous diminuez votre
le montant vous comprends donc c'était
une décision du client c'est donc des
gouverneurs de la banque centrale
européen simplement ces gouverneurs la
banque centrale européen surtout depuis
la décision de cour constitutionnelle
allemande du 5 mai il ya deux jours non
peut-être regarder à deux fois parce que
il ya quand même encore une fois on se
parlait dans quelques instants
mais des contraintes juridiques mais la
première possibilité c'est celle là
un abandon de créance et le deuxième
possibilité dont on entend de plus en
plus aussi cette petite musique
récemment alors là encore mélenchon en
parle mais pas que
c'est de transformer cette dette en
rente perpétuelle
autrement dit c'est de dire oui c'est
vrai annuler la dette c'était un peu
embêtant parce que cette confiance
risque de disparaître et c'est bon on va
pas l'annuler nantes a décidé qu'elle et
amsterdam
on va refaire une rente on va la
convertir en iran je vous rappelle
qu'une rampe c'est très simple c'est que
vous voudrez vous payer les intérêts
dont on sait jamais capitale il y en a
plus d'ailleurs ça a été un mode de
financement classique sous l'ancien
régime et y compris au 19e siècle les
dernières ventes ont été remboursés par
balladur en 87 je crois des vieux machin
qui traînait due à la période de la
restauration et autres ainsi que la
rente pinay bon bref tout ça pour dire
que adel un autre moyen qu'on entend
dire c'est ok techniquement je n'annule
pas la dette donc je fais pas un abandon
de créance je reste à voir une créance
de mon bilan
ouf j'ai pas des fonds propres négatifs
mais finalement je décide que le capital
de la dette ne sera pas remboursé plus
que je convertis le capital en une rente
c'est à dire je ne mets pas d'échéance
au remboursement de la dette
bon c'est comme si effectivement on rase
gratis dans ce cas là parce que bon mais
je rappelle qu'il faut quand même
l'accord du créancier et là de la même
manière il est probable que le cours de
justice sans doute aiguillonné par les
milliers d'allemands qui régulièrement
viennent titiller la cour de karlsruhe
en disant que finalement tout ceci n'est
pas très orthodoxe met une sorte de oh
là là dessus infogrames avoir en tête
cependant jamais si on va à présent à
écouter emmanuel macron le 13 avril
dernier le chef de l'état a plaidé pour
une annulation massive des dettes des
pays les plus pauvres
on l'écouté vos réactions juste après
nous devons aussi savoir aider nos
voisins d'afrique à lutter contre le
virus plus efficacement à les aider
aussi sur le plan économique en annulant
massivement leurs dettes alors le 15
avril à la dernier à l'issue d'une
conférence de presse virtuelle les
ministres des finances du g20 ont décidé
de suspendre pendant 12 mois la dette
des pays les plus pauvres parmi ces pays
40 en afrique
pas d'annulation donc mais un moratoire
olivier
c'est suffisant qu'elle est qu'elle est
aujourd'hui l'urgence d'aller annuler la
dette de pays africains
alors que on est en pleine déconfiture
en france d'abord qui s'occupe de la
france d'abord qui s'occupe de ce qui se
passe chez lui on verrait ça ira déjà
beaucoup mieux
là il veut annuler la dette africaine de
toute façon la dette africaine elle est
annulée
périodiquement dans l'histoire vous
regardez c'est rarissime qu'ils aient
rembourser quoi que ce soit elle est
annulée
périodiquement donc c'est pas baissé pas
des prêts qu'on leur fait céder dont 1
ça s'appelle pas un emprunt ça n'a
jamais été un emprunt c'est des dons et
cd donc qui malheureusement arrivent
quand même très très peu sur la tête des
habitants mais beaucoup sur la tête des
dirigeants
merci de vos cannes alors là le présent
vaqueront il a fait cette annonce a été
suivie derrière derrière le par une
autre annonce du g20 cette fois ci c'est
bien le voilà et un moratoire c'est pas
une annulation un moratoire c'est une
suspension à vos suspendez le paiement
des intérêts ou du principal et c'est
pas une annulation
donc je suis pas tout à fait d'accord
dans le sens où pour dire que les dettes
africaines ont été annulés non elles ont
été suspendues ce qui est un peu
hypocrite d'ailleurs parce qu'on dit bon
vous inquiétez pas vous paierez plus
tard à la fin de dire vous paierez plus
tard c'est vrai qu'il sait pas
remboursés mais techniquement il n'y a
pas d'annulations je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez mais il y avait un grand
mouvement des ong qui s'appelait le
jubilé 2000 comme son nom l'indiqué en
2000 qui avait pour vocation de annulé
mais au sens cette fois-ci abandon de
créances comme je l'expliquais tout à
l'heure les dettes des pays les plus
pauvres
tout le monde avait dit c'est très bien
on y va et c'est enfin nul est bon à la
fin des courses d'annulation il y en a
quasiment pas eu ça était que quelques
milliards les rares pays à avoir annulé
sa des pays scandinaves qui ont vraiment
annuler les autres ils ont fait des
suspensions des moratoires en disant bon
vous ne rembourserait plus tard c'est
pas pareil
donc attention aux mots qu'on emploie et
tout ceci en plus se fait dans un cadre
assez différent de celui dont on parle
avec la bce
ce que ces moratoires sont faits sous
l'égide finalement du club de paris ake
cette instance de créanciers
internationaux qui décide finalement
avec les débiteurs et les différents
débiteurs des pays les plus pauvres les
les
les techniques qui vont être mises en
oeuvre pour suspendre ou annuler tout ou
partie des dettes
est ce que c'est une bonne idée moi en
tous les cas c'est puis les pays les
plus pauvres ne rembourseront pas donc
garder une créance dans le bilan au
passé qu'elle sera jamais remboursé
c'est c'est même pas les hypocrites ça
n'a pas de sens c'est comptablement
inexactes vous serez dans une entreprise
industrielle et commerciale votre
commissaire aux comptes vous dirait bon
ben vous pressez ça par pertes et
profits donc continuer de faire un
moratoire n'a pas de sens il faut
annuler cd merci beaucoup et hubert de
vauplane l'avare était parmi nous dans
cette émission je rappelle que vous êtes
avocat et ancien banquier
olivier c'est l'heure des questions cash
olivier parmi les questions qui vous
sont adressés cette semaine est celle
d'audrey vernon dans un monde idéal que
devrait faire gouvernements et banques
centrales pour assurer une vie digne aux
citoyens quels seraient les changements
possibles est positif pour la planète et
pour les gens est-ce qu'on pourrait
vivre mieux
il y avait écouté pour ça je pense que
la réponse malheureusement serait
beaucoup trop longue des changements il
en faut simplement je pense qu'il faut
changer sa manière de penser il faut
changer surtout les gens qui sont aux
commandes parce que vous ne pouvez pas
changer les choses avec des gens qui
nous ont mis là où on est aujourd'hui et
qui nous ont conduits et on voit qu'ils
ne sont pas des gérants ni des gérants
quand c'est le calme plat ni des gérants
quand c'est la crise encore moins et
donc
je pense qu'il faut d'abord changer les
hommes et ensuite on pourra discuter des
idées et des idées il y en a des
centaines et des centaines et ce serait
beaucoup trop long à cette heure-ci de
l'émission on passe à la question
d'alexis 94 les dégâts sur l'économie
vont-ils mettre en risque les assureurs
et les banquiers évidemment évidemment
je crois qu'on n'a encore rien vu
aujourd'hui on est confiné il y avait
des gars qui sont en train de se faire
énorme
chez les indépendants chez les petites
bêtes dans les petites pme et caetera et
qui vont se transformer en créances
irrécouvrables et à ce moment-là ça
mettra en risque les assureurs et les
banquiers vous avez beaucoup aussi de
sortie de cash parce qu'il ya des gens
qui sont obligés de vivre qui en ont
consommé leur trésorerie qui commence à
taper dans leur épargne et et ça
évidemment ça fait ça va faire des trous
chez les banquiers et dans les
assurances et puis sur les marchés
financiers les choses ne sont sont loin
d'être finie et donc là aussi vous allez
avoir des pertes massives donc il ne
faut pas croire comme le dit madame
lagarde madame lagarde que les banques
sont dans une meilleure position
aujourd'hui quand de qu'en 2007 2008 et
donc malheureusement elles sont dans une
position qui pour moi est bien pire et
donc vous aurez des problèmes dans les
banques et vous aurez des problèmes dans
les assurances 1 c'est une évidence
merci à beaucoup olivier c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de votre fidélité
n'oubliez pas de poser vos questions à
olivier delamarche sur les réseaux
sociaux sachez aussi que tout à nos
précédentes aux émissions sont
disponibles en replay sur notre site
internet
rt france a pointé v on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
en attendant olivier c'est à vous pour
le mot de la fin regardez le titre de
l'émission qui était
l'annulation de dettes pour enrayer la
crise je ne savais pas que l'annulation
d' est constitué un vaccin